kim and kourtney kardashian have their
assist chloe's back when it comes to her
love life hashtag
the source tells e.t chloe's big sisters
are urging her to get back in the dating
pool crazy turns out kim and court who
are both booed up at the moment kim with
pete davidson and court with her fiance
travis barker want coco to join them on
double dates et's source shares that
both kim and court have guys in mind for
khloe kim a friend of pete's and
courtney a friend of travis's i love it
but get this chloe does not want kim and
courtney involved in her love life for
specific reasons
the source says that if the tv
personality gets set up she knows her
sisters will be sending group texts
about it immediately quote chloe wants
it to be organic and not have her whole
family know a play-by-play you just have
to
deal with it it is what it is and then
there's the fact that they have very
different taste in guys our source adds
it's an inside joke between the trio
chloe says pete and travis are so
opposite from her usual type plus chloe
is all good being single our source says
she's happy by herself but will start
dating when she's ready for now chloe is
focusing on being mom to her
three-year-old daughter true i'm just
super happy and content and i'm focused
on work and like taking care of me my
body and soul and true our source says
chloe is interested in falling in love
again but adds quote chloe's not ready
for that kind of commitment right now
and is happy just chilling for a bit of
course coco's also still kind of fresh
off a breakup from her ex nba star
tristan thompson the two most recently
parted ways for good after tristan owned
up to fathering a child with another
woman while he and chloe were together i
think something that we've always stayed
true to is that we want to film really
what we're going through and even if
it's not crazy salacious and it might
not be something for ratings like some
other shows do we've always stayed true
to who we are as chloe told variety fans
will get a front row seat to that drama
on the family's new hulu reality series
quote i wish i never had to talk about
that because it's not a fun thing to
talk about but it is part of my journey
in life so we will see it on the show i
just want to live my life and be happy
and variety confirms tristan will be on
the hulu series which will have a faster
turnaround time than their old show
keeping up that's the beauty of hulu
we're streaming and we get to have a
much quicker turnaround than previously
and we're really excited they're here
now in the back shooting with us and
we're so happy to be you know up and
rolling again
[Music]
you